خطروا الركود واصل التربص بالاقتصاد
العالمي والتحذيرات تتوالى بهذا الخصوص
اخرها تلك الصادره عن البنك الدولي الذي
انضم الى قائمه المؤسسات التي دقت ناقوس
الخطر بخصوص تهديد الركود على الاقتصاد
العالمي البنك الدولي قال ان الاقتصاد
العالميه سيقترب بشكل خطير من الركود خلال
العام الجاري مدفوع عن بضعف النمو في جميع
الاقتصادات الكبرى بالعالم كما خفض البنك
الدولي توقعته لنمو الاقتصادي العالمي هذا
العام الى نحو 1.7 فقط مقارنه مع توقعاته
السابقه البالغه ثلاثه في المئه
وتنبؤات البنك الدولي هذه تنظر بازمه
اقتصاديه خلال العام الحالي فاذا ثبتت
الدقه هذه التوقعات سنكون امام الثالث
اضعف نمو اقتصادي سنوي في ثلاثه عقود بعد
الركود الشديد الذي نتج عن الازمه الماليه
العالميه لعام 2008 والركود الناجم عن
جائعه فايروس كورونا لعام 2020 الاكثر من
ذلك نبه البنك الدولي الى ان ضعف
الاستثمار سيؤدي الى تدهور قطعي التعليم
والصحه في الدول الفقيره وكان التوقعات
مماثله قد صدرت قبل اسبوع من صندوق النقد
الدولي الذي اكد ان ثلث العالم سيقع في
ركود هذا العام